research continues tonight for the men
police say are responsible for shooting
and killing two people on the west side
of the valley the shooting happened
friday night on cindy sue street that's
near rancho and vegas drive the family
of one of the victims spoke to victoria
saha they tell her they want answers as
to why the man and woman were targeted
a memorial now sits at the crime scene
after 19 year old samir smith and 24
year old deanna marie diaz were killed
in this apartment friday night smith
lived just two doors down from here he
was with diaz in her apartment when the
two were gunned down we always stuck
close together samir smith's mom and
older brother are still trying to figure
out why smith a young man who kept to
himself and never got in trouble became
the victim of gun violence i moved out
here from chicago to get kids away from
shootings and
my son died out here from getting shot
investigators say smith and his neighbor
deanna diaz were inside her apartment
when two men knocked on the door diaz
answered but smith and the two men
started arguing that's when both were
shot i just peeked my head out and
i screamed out samia's name to see if he
would respond to me
and
he didn't smith's brother nadir heard
the shots from two doors down and ran
over i didn't see any type of like pain
in his face or anything it's just
i think him seeing me kind of like put
him at peace a bit families say smith
and diaz were very close and spent a lot
of time together but believe he was at
the wrong place at the wrong time he
didn't have a police record
so
i had to go and identify him on tuesday
morning diaz's distraught family was
seen moving her things out of her
apartment off camera her cousin who
witnessed the shooting tells me one of
the suspects had a ski mask on in the
meantime smith's mom has a message for
the men who took her son's life when you
get caught your family is going to be
hurt too
your family your mom is going to hurt
too
smith's mom says that since her son was
always a giver she has chosen to donate
his body to science metro police have
not made any arrests in this case and if
you have any information about the
suspects you are asked to call crime
stoppers that number is 702-385-5555